ceux qui votent style autour de la table
si vous deviez partir un mois sur une
île déserte avec un des gars au ou une
femme à lui bien jean michel mr nobody
il faut l'écouter sur europe 1 alors
anne on est revenu au rouge
oui c'est moi que vous y mettez là mais
j'aime beaucoup ça va ça vous va très
bien toujours amoureuse ça se voit c'est
ce qu'il faut de style autour de la
table si vous deviez partir un mois sur
une île déserte avec un des gars au ou
une femme à l'huile et bien sûr michel
mary jane a divorcé bon ouais comme
maintes fois à non pas comme lui
spectacle parler de la vie chante evans
et avec le divorce et c'est ce qui est
plus chaud dans le libre maintenant non
mais c'est c'est ça peut il ya des
moments c'est difficile et après ça va
csh c1 c'est un bouleversement dans la
vie
moi j'étais 25 ans donc ouais c'est pas
tous les trois ans - bah oui c'est vrai
il faut se calmer lucile pas contrat de
mariage ici le début ça va être entre
vous et matthieu delormeau le premier
arrivé à deux points d'accord à 2 le
dentiste d'enora mais deux jours pour
lui soigner une dent non mais ça va les
gars les vannes
combien de temps va-t-il mettre pour lui
soigner ses 134 dont way 268 bah bravo 2
à notre histoire vous foutez toujours la
gueule des politiques mais si vous
deviez choisir un gouvernement pour un
dîner et plus si affinités vous
prendriez qui a cassé toi tu vas direct
on attend qu'elle fasse pas dire oui
mais toi tu te fais pas chier le
président c'est tout et mme t et dont
philippe j'aime bien
baba kane et tout ça à l'hôtel va nous
faire tout le gouvernement alors il loue
les partis noirs j'aimerais paul douat
l'est pas du tout appareil ou pas kader
adore la merguez sachant qu'il lui en
faut 8 par jour
combien mon style en une semaine khadr
56 c'est lui qui adhèrent est-ce que tu
étais première de la classe
non j'étais dans les cinq premiers mais
je bavarde eh bah ouais mais c'est
toujours bas marne trop bas la basse et
sa profonde dire monsieur je suis pas
d'accord ah ouais
ah oui j'en rêve c'était la rebelle de
l'est qui a nom madoff fait t'as fait
quoi comme études déjà j'ai fait
sciences po
les loyers en bas la science la science
de la potasse et des blousons et à un
bon prix plutôt brun au blond grillades
à trouver un nom alors je vais vous dire
je connais je connais les femmes elle
n'a pas trouvé mais elle a des délires
elle reçoit des sms
elle reçoit des whatsapp alors qu'est ce
que fait ce soir ha ha ha raconte pas sa
vie tant pis mais on est en direct
bah oui on dirait qu'il y en a pas un
pour cent bouffer une émission de télé
en fait une fois je vous ai fait draguer
par un prof on avait froid 7 à sciences
po donc j'étais major aussi et il m'a
donné savaient ce qu'ils sentaient un
parfum que je trouvais érotique
non oui bon ben voilà donc juste ça et
après il m'a appelé c'est pas un peu
j'en ai voulu me proposer les sujets un
truc j'ai pas donné suite je trouvais ça
bizarre quoi il voulait donner les
sujets à l'avant ce serait bien
concevoir pour qu'on parle des sujets
sur lesquels était quand même assez
vieux parce que je pense qu'il avait au
moins 40 ans ouais enfin 20 ans et j'ai
inscrit qui votre style autour de la
table si vous deviez partir un mois sur
une île déserte avec un des garçons ou
une femme à l'huile et bien jean michel
maire à lui
[Musique]